this summer we all went on a bike Aires
vacation with New Horizons to the Pluto
system and NASA like a road trip mom
documented every moment but the pictures
a sentence home aren't as pretty the New
Horizons team uses them to create
measurements of Pluto's surface and
speculate about the door splendas
geology and atmosphere those pitchers of
course become pretty videos like this
one NASA recently made of a Pluto
flyover look at all those mountains
craters and valleys feels like you were
really there cruising by in your x-wing
fighter hey we're playing make-believe
so why not a few days ago the agency
released another flyover this time of
Pluto's and largest moon Tehran check it
out the chair on flyby starts at about
1,100 miles above the surface then dips
down to 40 miles to zip over the moon's
1,000 mile long equatorial canyon system
New Horizons is long past Pluto now but
we still have our memories the memories
you